sous-titré en grande partie par Antoine-Kvc-
oh pardon !
Je faisais une véritable oeuvre d'art
...
EXCELLENT !
Les amis aujourd'hui nous somme sur "Passpartout"
Non il ne s'agit pas du jeu de cette légende de la TV française
"Je suis Passe-partout, du fort Boyard"
Il s'agit de l'histoire d'un autre français qui veut percer dans le monde de l'art pour pouvoir s'acheter des baguettes de pain et du vin !
Voilà !
C'est un peu cliché, bon voilà a mon avis ça pas été fait par un français
MAIS !
Je vais aujourd'hui percer sur le marché du tableau
De la toile !
Mais pas la toile d'Internet, la toile euh le tissu mec
C'est partit !
Le but c'est très simple c'est de faire des œuvres...
De les vendre de plus en plus cher
De déménager dans des endroit de mieux en mieux
Et d'avoir une vie de mieux en mieux
Vous avez compris ?
Hooooo...
Ce pauvre jeune homme vit dans un garage...
Il n'arrive pas à percer dans le monde de l'art
Son histoire étant très triste nous allons dessiner un homme très triste
Avec la coupe de cheveux un peu à la mode: rasé sur les côtés, longs sur le dessus
PUTAINS j'ai fais un dessins de ouf là !
Regardez comme c'est bien fait
C'est incroyable, les larmes coulent sur son visage
Humide et plein de sébum
Car il n'a pas l'argent pour acheter le savon pour se le laver
Ok. Il est là c'est un tableau très fort en émotion on va l'appeler : Sadness
Pourquoi Sadness ?? Parce que les français préférant tous les noms
en pas français auront plus tendance à l'acheter si je marque en anglais
Attend ! C'est bon le mec de la boulangerie d'a côté qui vient vendre ces baguettes
sur le... sur mon... mon... mon local de professionnel
Abusé ! Et faut que j'en fasse une autre !
OHLALA !!
Que ce qu'on pourrait raconter ? Bah vous savez quoi on va dessiner une baguette #Amixem
Oh ?! Mauvaise énergie je ne l'aime pas
Mais c'est l'histoire de ma vie Cynth. Pourquoi tu fais ça ??
Comment te permets-tu ?
Ah d'accord ok, bon vu qu'on est dans le cliché je vous dessine une guitare peut être que vous aimerez mieux
Maggie qui nous dit : "C'est effectivement un tableau de merde !"
Merci Maggie
C'est bien mais c'est bien le respect est présent
Donc en gros on vient de payer nos factures et on a perdu 80 dollars
Peut être que la baguette, le pain français bien chaud qui sort du four va nous sauver
On va l'appeler : Bread
Parce que si on l'appelait pain, ça ferait 0 vente
Allez il y a bien un mec qui va aimer
J'aimerai quelque chose de plus frais nous dit George
Huuum, huuum
Bah va sur les quais de la Seine et ferme ta gueule steuplait
Ah là tu verras il fait frais ! Ah là WOW !
Bon je vais essayer de dessiner quelque chose qui résume parfaitement
l'émotion de notre personnage à ce moment précis
Voilà ! Un bon : Vos Gueules ! sur mon tableau !
Peut être que ça va lancer ma carrière peut être !
Sacre bleu ! Où est l'originalité ??
Eh benjamin frère, franchement retourne vendre tes baguettes à George qui est actuellement
sur les quais de Seine, va lui vendre tes baguettes et foutez moi la paix !
Peut être qu'ils aiment tous ce qui est abstrait ?
(désolé pour vous oreilles)
Voilà ça. Vous voyez dans ce tableau l'énergie transmise
L'énergie de plusieurs bombes nucléaires qui sont retransmises à l'écrit
Ce gros trait qui passe devant l'oeuvre abstraite elle cachée derrière *tousse*
Bref, on va l'appeler steuplé achète le frère
Voilà c'est très bien
ah il en reste un à faire !?
mais là...là je sais plus là
on va juste faire...
...Une barbe...
Voilà.
Où alors ça en vrai ça peut être un visage de quelqu'un
et c'est là qu'est la subtilité...
...À l'envers
voilà regardez
c'est ça qui est intéressant avec ce tableau, c'est qu'au premier abord on croirait une barbe ...
et puis quand on tourne la tête on s'aperçoit c'est une tête à l'envers
bien sûr c'est excellent !
c'est énorme !
"Provoking and shocking. I frickin' love it !"
OOOOOOOOOOOH !
Maggie a aimé l'art abstrait l'énergie des bombes nucléaires !
"Stp achète le frère" a été vendu pour 10€
YES !
Ok j'ai compris comment ils veulent qu'on leur parle
Du coup celui là on va l'appeler "met moi bien cousin"
C'est très bien ça
"Pourquoi peins tu avec aucune passion ?" Maggie, Maggie...
Je l'ai déjà dit au moins 18 fois, je fais ça par passion OK?
Et certainement pas pour la thune !!
put*in
"Breaking News, les scientifiques viennent de découvrir un vaisseau spatial"
heiiiiiiiin
Ok, j'ai compris le message
Voiiiiiiiilà
Hop on a fait la miniature d'Amixem mais bon c'est pas
OOOOOOOHH
Allez hop, le doigt d'honneur on l'a dégagé, personne veut acheter un fuck
Bon c'est dommage, un fuck dans ton salon mec, ça met bien
ça met les points sur les i quand t'as des invités
OOH
L'UFO il l'achète à 113 dollars
Mon dieu !
Mais merci les aliens d'être passé sur Terre
put*in vous m'avez mis tellement bien
Je vais pouvoir acheter du vin de 10 d'âge
j'ai une idée
un peu sobre, un concept sobre mais efficace...
...c'est de dessiner des fruits.
de la manière la plus sobre possible (bien évidemment)
voilà là on est bien
non, c'est pas toi quand t'avais de l’acné à douze ans
c'est juste euh...une fraise
Voilà
Très bon concept !
Ok, je propose tout simplement attention...
Grosse œuvre
(Magnifique...)
Voilà
c'est...c'est abstrait
Chacun l'interprète comme il le veut
Certains y verront un pissenlit, d'autres y verront un arc-en-ciel
On ne sait pas.
"Achète-le ou je te plante"
Voilà comme ça au moins on est...c'est réglé
Oh
10 euros pour cette œuvre abstraite incroyable
je...je prends je prends je prends
"des gens disent que la passion et la créativité de Passpartout est le truc le plus cool dans la rue actuellement."
YES !!!
Après ok...
...les gens me prennent pour un dieu mais ils achètent mes tableaux moins cher qu'ils payent leur menu au Mcdo
quand même donc bon.
oh attend mec ça met combien de temps à sortir de la rue là  ?
franchement ?
mec c'est plus rapide de percer dans l'art dans la vraie vie ou dans ce jeu quoi ?
AH !
16 euros
pour le...le...le...le...
je sais plus ce que j'avais mis
mais c'est pas grave vas-y je prends 16 balles
ah c'est parti
OH P*TAIN LE BUZZ !
comment je suis en train de buzzer
tout le monde veut acheter mes tableaux d'un coup qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
oh les hipster disent que je suis devenu trop populaire et qu'ils achèteront plus mes œuvres
ET BAH JE M'EN BAT LES *OUILLES !
BARREZ-VOUS AVEC VOS BAGUETTES !
rien à foutre...
le amis j'ai une grande annonce...
je tiens un vrai concept cette fois
(jeu de mot INCROYABLE ! ^^)
voilà
très bien donc il nous reste 8 euros d'argent de poche
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est bientôt la fin de cette VIDÉO ?
What the fuck mec j'ai fait 600 œuvres d'art...
INCROYABLES !
en ville on arrête pas de parler de moi
mais en attendant je dors dans un garage
HEIN
sur un lit humide
qui comporte un maximum de cloportes
je vais faire une fusée parce que je rêve de m'en aller loin
avec derrière du feu
du feu il y aura du rouge
brrrr *bruit de fusée*
et je veux atterir sur la lune
ici
et là dans le cockpit c'est moi
c'est moi là qui suis debout et qui veut aller sur la lune parce que j'en ai marre
de cette vie  :'d
voilà l'interprétation sera pas mal du tout je trouve comme ça
c'est sympathique ouais
ouais c'est vraiment pas mal ouais...
OH!
44 dollars pour la fusée
oh il a compris le message, il a compris la métaphore à travers ce dessin parfaitement illustré
ok j'pense avoir compris un truc...
j'pense qu'ils se basent sur le temps que t'as mis à faire le tableau
attend, si ça se trouve mec j'ai trouvé comment le jeu marche
et je vais devenir la plus grande star de l'histoire de l'art de l'histoire de ce jeu
je vais mettre un maximum de temps, on va faire du noir
on va attendre une minute à chaque fois
♫Une minute plus tard ♪
ok...attend mec si ça marche c'est GÉNIAL !
je vais devenir une star de ouf!
*réalise*
c'est ça mec regarde
97 il me propose
*a une idée en tête*
les affaires commencent !
(merci SQUEEZIE pour la musique ça fait moins à sous-titrer ^^)
(beau gosse moi je dis ! ^^)
oh !
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe !?
*met son casque...*
aah il a écrit un article sur moi °o°
c'est enfin l'acte suivant !?
ooh !
on va vivre ailleurs que dans un garage !?
(Bruit chelou)
CHAMPAGNE !
qui en veut ? j'ai que de l'eau mais c'est pas grave
la fête n'en sera que meilleure
oooh j'ai mon propre atelieer !?
DAMN IT !
oh non par contre il faute pas une autre heure de jeu pour atteindre le truc d'après ?
non parce que là mec à un moment euh...
oooh !
275 d...d...euros de facture le loyer là ?
serai-ce ...
la fin de passe-partout ?
la fin d'un homme si pure et si doux ?
la fin d'un homme exceptionnel ?
la fin d'un homme...
...qui a su rester fort même dans les pires moment.
"qu'il est méchant !"
la fin d'un véritable artiste
passe-partout...
...je...
merci pour tous ces moment, merci pour toutes ces œuvres d'art et...
...à bientôt.
(calme toi)
(CALME TOI ENFIN !)
passe-partouuuuuut ! ♥
et voilà les amis cx'est la fin de cette vidéo sur "Passpartout"
n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plue
bon mes œuvres ont un peu convaincu les hipsters
puis quand je suis devenu connu ils m'aimaient plus
je suis triste
après, est-ce que ces gens qui vont à des soirées mondaines, savent faire ça ?
(il est trop fort !)
ET BIEN NON !
bon j'arrête à tout jamais le dessin et je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo portez-vous bien
oh le mec il dit au revoir alors qu'on voit même plus sa tête !
on sait même pas si  en vrai il parle vraiment ou si c'est une voix off qu'il a rajouté au montage
♫tu lu lu tu tu tu tu tu tu tu tu lu lu tu tu tu tu tu tu tin ahouwaw♪